en el vídeo pasado te empecé a platicar
acerca de la elasticidad de la demanda y
calculamos algunos numeritos para este
ejemplo de tacos ahora lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es asegurarme que de
manera intuitiva y de manera matemática
entendamos qué significan estos
numeritos de acá y sobre todo porque
había una cosa más o menos extraña
sucediendo en el vídeo pasado que era la
siguiente en cada uno de los escenarios
cuando pasábamos de ave de ave de
shehadeh o bien de a efe en cualquiera
de los tres el precio bajaba en 1 lo voy
a poner que el precio bajaba en 1 y
bajaba en 1 y bajar en 1 y la cantidad
aumentaba en 2 y aumentaba en 2 y
aumentaba en 2 entonces esto quiere
decir que teníamos una curva de demanda
lineal verdad baja en un aumento en dos
bajen uno aumenta en dos y bajen un
aumento en dos es una curva de demanda
de demanda lineal sin embargo aún
teniendo esta situación nos sucedía que
la elasticidad de la demanda era muy
distinta aquí teníamos menos 5.67 menos
1 y menos sube 0.18 entonces digo claro
muy seguramente debes estar sospechando
que esto se debe a que en vez de estar
haciendo cambios esté así normal y tos
buenos divisiones de cambios estamos
haciendo divisiones con porcentajes
entonces vamos a ver que realmente pues
tiene que ver con eso ok entonces bueno
si en efecto sea así nada más fuera
digamos cambio de cantidad entre cambio
de precio pues nos quedaría 2 entre 1 o
2 entre menos uno en cada uno de los
casos pero vamos a ver vamos a ir caso
por caso a ver qué podemos decir al
respecto primero aquí estamos pasando de
a a b entonces cómo le hacíamos para
calcular la elasticidad de la demanda
pues empezábamos calculando el cambio
porcentual de la cantidad entonces acá
arriba en el numerador nos queda un
cambio porcentual más o menos grande ya
que se debía esto pues mira aquí
teníamos un cambio de dos y
porcentualmente cómo se comporta este 2
con respecto al promedio de 12-4 bueno 2
y 4 su promedio es 3 entonces más o
menos nos queda bueno nos queda dos
tercios entonces se cambio porcentual es
más o menos como de un 66% hay un cambio
porcentual grande de la cantidad sin
embargo en el precio hay un cambio
porcentual pequeño digo hay un cambio de
-1 pero porcentualmente s menos 1 es muy
pequeño comparado con el promedio de 8 y
9 o sea con 8.5 o sea s menos 1
comparado con el 8.5 es muy pequeño y
por tanto aquí tenemos un porciento pues
más o menos del orden de 10 15% algo de
ese estilo entonces aquí hay un cambio
porcentual como de 67 en el numerador y
en el denominador hay un cambio
porcentual como de 15% y entonces al
hacer la división nos quedaba este
numerito de acá el 5.67 que en magnitud
era grande verdad en magnitud era mayor
que 1 va entonces eso se debía justo a
cómo se comporta el cambio con respecto
a más o menos donde estamos en ese
momento por eso el cambio porcentual
bueno en una situación como ésta pasando
de a a b en la cual el valor absoluto de
la elasticidad de la demanda es mayor
que 1 le voy a poner aquí el valor
absoluto de la elasticidad de la demanda
es mayor que 1 se dice que el bien es el
generalmente elástico
elástico plástico va entonces aquí el
bien es elástico ahora pasemos de c&a de
bueno de sea de lo que hacíamos era este
menos uno ahora lo dividimos pero entre
5 y este 2 lo dividimos pero ahora entre
10 entonces ahora qué va a suceder con
los porcentajes ahí esto de dividir
entre el promedio acuérdate acuérdate de
que era para que diera lo mismo en la
elasticidad pasando de ese a de que
desde hace pero va que entonces pasaba
con los porcentajes en esta situación de
acá pues ahora tenemos un 1 dividido
entre 5 un quinto eso más o menos es
común 20% verdad bueno de hecho es un 20
por ciento y de este lado tenemos un 2
dividido entre un 10 eso es un 1 entre 5
otra vez es otra vez un 20 por ciento
entonces esto porcentualmente era un
cambio de 20% y acá era un cambio de 20
por ciento también y por esta razón
pasando de sea de deseo desde hace como
quieras pensarlo pasando de sea de
teníamos que la un y que la elasticidad
era menos 1 y qué valor absoluto era de
1 hora porque todos estos nos están
saliendo negativos pues justo tiene que
ver con que la curva de demanda va hacia
abajo con que tiene pendiente negativa
bueno pero entonces tenemos esto acá al
menos 111 y ahora en esta situación
cuando esto de aquí es
igual a 1 cuando el valor absoluto de la
elasticidad de la demanda es 1 se dice
que tiene que el bien digamos en este
caso los tacos tiene elasticidad
unitaria
elasticidad
finalmente en términos porcentuales que
nos pasaba pasando de a efe ah pues
ahora tenemos un cambio de 1 aquí pero
es mucho más grande comparado a donde
estamos verdad ahora estamos como en el
1 y en el 2 el promedio es 1.5 y ahora
tenemos un cambio porcentual de 11
comparado con 1.5 es un cambio como del
66% es un cambio de dos tercios y
entonces es un cambio grandote
porcentualmente ahora en el precio
entonces ahora tenemos un cambio
porcentual grande en el precio y en
cantidad ahora tenemos un 2 entre 10 y
72 entre 17 que porcentualmente es mucho
más chiquito también está como que será
por el 10% 9% algo de ese estilo más o
menos como 6% no sé muy bien pero el
chiste es que ahora este 2 es muy
chiquito comparado con la cantidad en la
que estábamos ya la que pasamos entonces
como ahora ese porcentaje es más pequeño
y estamos dividiendo entre un porcentaje
más grande la elasticidad de la demanda
se hace muy chiquita se hace muy cercana
a cero entonces es negativa es muy
cercana a cero
amira y me falta un 8
0.18 entonces 0.18 aquí es 0.18 en valor
absoluto y entonces ahora tenemos el
caso de que la elasticidad de la demanda
en valor absoluto es menor que 1 y en
este caso se dice que el bien es
inelástica
inelástico muy bien entonces más o menos
por eso aparecen estas elasticidades de
demandas distintas tienen que ver con
cómo estamos calculando el porcentaje y
bueno bueno tiene que ver mucho con qué
es porcentaje para empezar y pues
también el hecho de que nos dé lo mismo
de ir para un lado para el otro tiene
que ver con que en vez de dividir entre
un extremo dividamos entre el promedio
de los dos extremos